[Musik]
hey leute wie man heute was aus dem ofen
und zwar hähnchenschenkel mit gemüse und
einer richtig leckere marinade
das tolle ist ihr könnt das richtig
schön im voraus vorbereiten und dann
abends ist in den ofen schieben
ich habe mir meine marinaden zutaten und
ich gebe jetzt ganz einfach alles in
meine schüssel
wir fangen jetzt mit dem honig an der
gibt so ein bisschen süße und zum honig
passt immer ganz kurz sojasauce
für diese säure es sich da könnt ihr
jeden beliebigen es sich nehmen die ich
mit dazu dann habe ich hier meine
klassiker tomaten und paprika markt das
ist jetzt so ein bisschen türkisch
arabisch angehaucht gebe ich auch müsse
zu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt haben wir so zwei gewürzt sein
gemüsebrühe und paprika flocken bei den
paprika flocken nämlich die süßen es
gibt ja auch scharf aber das wäre dann
zu schaffen können so ein bisschen
scharfe paprika flop mit dazu geben wenn
es möglich und damit das ganze auch
schon flüssig wird wasser und für den
geschmack noch mal olivenöl
[Musik]
jetzt schnappt ihr euch einen
schneebesen und verrührt alles gut bis
es schön verbunden ist und klümpchen
freies vor allem als nächstes schnappt
ihr euch eure auflaufform oder wie ich
jetzt ein tiefes backblech und gebt eure
hähnchenschenkel drauf und es geht auch
mit hähnchen wings also münchen flügeln
oder indem zum beispiel hähnchenbrust
das würde auch funktionieren das ist
auch kein problem
und jetzt schön die vorbereitete
marinade darübergeben und dann müsste er
auch darauf aufpassen dass überall
marinade drankommt ihr könnt auch gern
noch mal wenden und drehen das alles von
allen seiten schön bedeckt ist
[Musik]
so erleben ihr könnt das ganze jetzt
natürlich ein paar stunden marinieren
lassen wenn es der geschmack schön
intensiv falls sie keine zeit hat dann
lasst es einfach ansonsten könnt ihr das
ja auch wie gesagt gerne im voraus
vorbereiten ihr macht sie zum beispiel
morgens und schiebt es dann abends in
den backofen das kenne ich jetzt ganz
kurz an die seite denn wir machen jetzt
mit dem gemüse weiter ich habe mich ja
jetzt hier für rote paprika entschieden
ich habe die cd normal und noch spitz
paprika und ihr könnt auch jegliche
andere gemüsesorten da reingeben was ich
auch da hat sind kartoffeln und bei den
kartoffeln ist es so wenn ihr das
vorbereitet und die kartoffeln schon mal
auf schneidet dann wird die oberfläche
ja schnell braun und deswegen gebe ich
das erst kurz vor dem backen darauf dass
geht der ratz fatz einfach nur vierteln
und aufs blech geben und dann werden die
auch gleichzeitig gab dann gehts
schneiden wir es auch paprika zusammen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und wir werden heute abend nicht hier
essen also kommt das pech nicht in mein
backofen sondern in das von hamms eltern
in machen dem nicht dort unser
fastenbrechen habe ich mich jetzt auch
dazu entschieden rote zwiebel mit rein
zu nehmen dann haben sie das familie ist
jetzt wie belastet also die mögen
zwiebeln sehr und ihr könnt natürlich
auch die normalen zwiebeln nehmen aber
ich mag es aus dem ofen immer gern wenn
es die roten sind
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich das geschnittene gemüse
ganz einfach auf das backblech zu sehr
auf unser hähnchen und dann könnt ihr
auch darauf achten dass überall so ein
bisschen marinade dran kommt damit auch
richtig lecker schmeckt am ende und die
kartoffeln gebe ich auch schon dazu dann
werden sie zwar ein bisschen brauchen
aber so kann ich euch dann das
endergebnis zeigen bevor sie den ofen
kommt
jetzt gebe ich wie gesagt die kartoffeln
schon dazu und dann habt ihr hauptspeise
und beilage in einem und wir machen
später noch reis dazu und servieren
joghurt und ich gebe euch einen tipp
also macht mich wie ich ihr könnt gerne
eine große schüssel nehmen und alles da
schon mal schön verkneten weil auf dem
backblech wird es ein bisschen eng
gerade aber ich warne euch vor damit ihr
das zuhause bisschen schöner hinkriegt
und jetzt warte ich nur noch auf das
egal und gäbe dass eine stunde vorher in
den backofen also ungefähr 45 bis 60
minuten bei 200 grad ober unterhitze ihr
könnt sie ab und zu mal durchchecken ob
das hähnchen gar ist und in der zeit
sind auch die kartoffeln und alles
andere schön klar und schön weich und
ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß
und nachmachen ich binde euch gleich
natürlich noch sehen ein wenn wir heute
abend dann bei hansas eltern sind und
wenn wir das ganze aus dem ofen holen
das zeige ich euch denn und ich
überlegte sogar später noch cashewkerne
also gerüstet oder sogar angebratene
darüber zu geben das stechen auch sehr
sehr lecker vor wie gesagt geht es bei
uns dazu reis und joghurt ich wünsche
euch jetzt ganz ganz viel spaß und
nachmachen verabschiede mich schon mal
an dieser stelle und sage bis zum
nächsten mal auf die key fitschen und
hinterlässt mir auf jeden fall ein
dummchen hier
[Musik]
[Applaus]